what's up guys my name is China I'm
still on holiday at the moment this time
I'm in Sweden uh and then this email
popped up in my inbox please tear my
code apart I just couldn't resist you
know so we're gonna take a look at
Cameron Otten who wrote hey channel so I
made this thing a while back in C plus
plus was intended really to be a game
more than an engine per se I got a
little stuck but recently went back and
fixed a couple things
all right guys we possibly might need to
bounce
um are you uh all right so joining me
for this code review is Peter who works
at Studio Channel he's a Hazel engineer
the camera doesn't seem to like to focus
on him because we all know that this is
my channel yep definitely Okay so we've
got a C plus plus thing it's a game more
than an engine recently starting to
think of my career and would like to
actually get into the industry and use
this code is good portfolio so this is
going to be like he wants us to be a
portfolio right and he wants me to tear
it apart so we're not going to be we're
going to be a bit roasty we're going to
be a bit harsh here I want to be a bit
realistic okay so object-oriented
programming he understands and sees its
strengths and weaknesses but ultimately
prefers to have Global functions I think
that's probably a good idea generally I
don't like it when people constrain
themselves to like a particular code
style right like it's yeah it's good
when when you use a mix of styles yeah
you should use like whatever fits
especially if you're using a language
like C plus class that obviously doesn't
like constrain you into specifically
being object oriented you know like
something like Java it's you know it's
often better to pick the right tool for
the job and I personally don't think
that any particular programming Paradigm
is necessarily 100 suited and perfect
for something like that yeah yeah like
you should definitely just use whatever
Paradigm fits the best for the task
alright so please look in depth with
this code there's a lot of neat stuff as
well as some hacky stuff but don't go
easy on me look at it as if you were
hiring someone and we're looking at
their competency as a programmer and yes
main is a mess I know I know okay so
it's always interesting to me when
people send in code
with like a hundred disclaimers because
like you know when you read the text
look look at it as if you were hiring
someone
and we're looking at their competency as
a programmer but then in the same
sentence actually no I mean there's a
full stop yes and maybe not the same
sentence but yes main is a mess I know I
know it's like maybe fix it up first and
then I'll look at it as if I was hiring
someone okay so this is the actual uh
project Itself by the way it's called
think it's got some nice looking Shadows
we'll do a quick look at that it's uh
basically Hazel's Shadow system yeah but
implemented not as well because it
doesn't look as good but it's pcss so
we've got some debug rendering and I
guess the physics is uh custom right
yeah it's from what I could tell it's
pretty much completely custom
um
and I'm not sure if all of these
um boxes are individual colliders I
highly doubt it but the debug rendering
would indicate that in which case they
most likely use some sort of
a sprout face algorithm I think they
might be because they sell remember the
cell kind of and the way that we we've
probably sure what the levels look like
I've had a quick browse yeah but yeah I
think this is basically kind of like
they've used like a tile map setup so
yeah so like this is what the levels
look like so I guess the they look like
nerds there's a free camera as well I
mean yeah it looks like just like a
little kind of physics demo slash level
layout yeah thing although
the mouse isn't like captured yeah the
mouse is hidden not locked but yeah here
we can actually see that it seems to be
using some sort of velocity expanded
um bounding box for doing basically a
broad face uh Collision check
um which you know is clever especially
when you have a lot of colliders
um
so like I'd say physics wise in terms of
the actual functionality of it it's not
bad
like it definitely seems to be working
and it's running pretty well although
some of the Collision checks aren't
quite accurate on certain corners
it's like you you can manage to get into
the actual geometry there all right so I
don't want this to be another video
about the build system
um Peter and I looked at the build
system
um and uh
I don't like it
yeah
um it's just a batch file like this
I'd had Echo off at the start we had to
uh disable that because we had to debug
the build scripts and disabling that
somehow fixed it yes so great yeah like
I mean my suggestion obviously is like
to use something like cmake or pre-make
I mean I don't know why I said yeah
preferably pre-produced primate but you
know using a build system is a lot
better than trying to write a script
like this
um obviously this only works on Windows
anyway and it only uses Visual Studio
which also begs the question why is this
not just a visual studio solution yeah
it was hard-coded to visual studio 2019
yeah which means oh yeah that's right we
also had to change that yeah anyway
we're not going to talk about the build
system in this video we're just going to
move on to the code which again does not
have a visual studio solution so we just
open up the full day in visual studio
and here we are in the main file all
right so here we are in the main
function Peter I want you to look at
this and tell me what you see if there's
anything that like jumps out at you and
if you were hiring someone for Studio
show no more juice say so I wouldn't say
that there's a lot of if for debugging
and
I will say that the code is not the most
readable just because there's
like a lot of this I would have grouped
into better kind of sections either by
using like a vlog scope or by simple
moving them into separate functions yeah
it's weird that this is all on the main
function yeah like I mean he did say
that main is kind of messy and stuff but
it seems like
all right let's take a look at this
quickly like how much stuff is in here I
think it's like 700 700 lines of code
but it's also like it's the it's the
entire application yeah like everything
from initializing sdl to loading meshes
and assets and shaders dispatch and draw
calls is in there as well yeah debug
rendering opengl code like I mean I mean
he did say that it's kind of more of a
by the way they don't apparently they
don't make good shares in Sweden
I mean it's a 10 year old chair
I think we need to go to IKEA now if
you're enjoying this roasting and you
want me to roast your code I mean sorry
review your code my mistake send it into
chair review gmail.com there'll be some
instructions in the description below
but if you're not quite ready for the
roasting if you're still a beginner then
there's an excellent free way that you
can learn computer science online with
sponsor of today's video brilliant.org
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of courses on
various stem topics thing that really
sets them apart in my opinion is they're
kind of visual and interactive and
engaging approach to learning they've
got some excellent kind of beginner
level computer science courses that will
really kind of hold your hand and gently
introduce you to being able to think
like a programmer and then I really
highly recommend their math courses
everything from like the Everyday Math
course which is excellent for beginners
through to things like algebra linear
algebra calculus stuff that is honestly
really useful to know if you're
programming things like this game engine
now as I mentioned Visual and
interactive they've got like these
widgets you can play with in their
bite-sized lessons taking this stuff in
visual really really important and
they'll also quiz you to make sure that
you're paying attention retaining this
information and learning now the best
thing about brilliant is that they have
a 30-day free trial you can just browse
their entire platform see what courses
they have available try them see if it
works for you for free just go to
brilliant.org the Cherno and if you do
want to like it they'd be nice enough to
offer the first 200 subscribers 20 off
an annual membership huge thank you to
brilliant.org as always for sponsoring
this video I've said this before by the
way in other code reviews and it's
always really difficult to not repeat
myself but I think it's really really
important to have an application like
file and class you know so that you can
just shove in all of the initialization
D initialization kind of code into one
place so that you're not polluting like
the main function there's also a lot of
renderer initialization related stuff
like that should be in the renderer
class you know there's so many different
Engine Systems that I'm seeing here that
really shouldn't be
just in one file and in one place like
this they should just be separated out I
can also kind of see why people do
things like this because it's I I think
a lot of it comes from them wanting to
just get it up and running and then
improving it afterwards but I think
there's a limit to to that because
like Fast iteration is good but you
should still not just dump everything
into a single place and keep it there
yeah
now I think that I think that the other
thing is like possibly when people don't
know what the architecture should be
yeah yeah because they haven't written
stuff you know like if you've built an
engine before and you know exactly like
okay I need a renderer I need an
application like file or whatever I need
like something to uh you know hold like
game stay like a scene you know the
concept of a scene system like if you
know all of that then that's great you
can just be like all right well I'm not
gonna waste time I know I need this file
this you you could almost just make like
all the classes up front leave them
empty and then fill them in as you go
because you know how it goes yeah
exactly you know but if you're like
doing this for the first time you might
not know enough about it to start making
structural decisions yeah and so you
might just kind of pull up everything
all into one place and then be like okay
I'm gonna do because I do this as well
like when if I if I if like let's just
say I'm implementing grass rendering or
something like I've never done before
I'm gonna sit down and I'm
across today yeah like it would be a
waste of time and also unnecessarily
difficult for me to go through
everything and just be like okay um I'm
Gonna Make This Grass generator class
I'm going to make like this grass cash
class or whatever I'm gonna have to make
like some renderer functions that are
going to I don't know build up some
storage buffers filled with grass blades
or whatever right like it it doesn't
make sense to me because I've never done
it before yeah so it might make more
sense for me to just be like here's a
function called do grass and I'm going
to put everything absolutely everything
there and then I'm going to go back
through it like once it works because
again step one I feel is always just
make it work definitely right like just
make it work and then once you've made
it work you can refactor it you can
iterate over it a few times to make it
more flexible
and more kind of maybe add more features
and works extendable as well in the
future yeah you know I think that's
generally speaking good philosophy to
have it's like
there's there's no no real point in
actually architecting this really
complex system if you don't actually
have anything working yet because you
don't necessarily know
what it's going to end up looking like
yeah you don't know exactly what you
wanted to to do essentially I think
if you have something already working
you can then work backwards from there
to some sort of API that you actually
like yeah I think another thing is like
recognizing potential like almost like
patterns and cards like you know the
code we're looking at right now on the
screen kind of coincidentally because we
just scrolled to a random place it's
like you know creating these Samplers
for textures yeah in opengl and like the
thing is you can kind of see the parts
here that are clearly the same right so
like these sample parameters are
identical they're just setting the
magnification and minification filters
to be linear then we need to set the
Border color and they're both being set
to wire here yeah um you know then we're
doing the wrapping and the
pair modes as well like all of this
stuff like this is a really good
kind of opportunity to take that and be
like all right how can I condense this
code
um
by potentially making like a texture
class which I mean it looks like there
is one oh but it's just a struck so see
this is like this is actually really
interesting because this this is kind of
where it's shying away from
object-oriented programming and going a
little bit more C style because what you
do there is you have structures of data
right so we just have a struct that is
just kind of a pod type plain old data
type there's no functions in here
there's no like deep kind of pointers to
other blocks of memory yeah there's just
four integers of like data and then the
functions around that like we have a
function like create texture which is
just a global function which will run
that so this is a very C style kind of
approach right yeah but I would argue
that like in this case
I feel like it's
not as good and you know a lot of this
is obviously personal preference so like
here's an example from Hazel you know
we're creating just a white texture
right and this white texture is just
something of the renderer stores because
whenever you need like you know
basically to kind of not have a texture
set or something that you can multiply
by to just get like you know because
white is one so if you multiply by a
white texture you'll you won't change
the original data uh and this is like
all of the code you know that does
I guess all of this yeah basically right
and it's way more flexible as well uh
because I mean well for one this doesn't
even include oh no the data is here okay
all right so that's so the white is the
border so we're not actually setting any
data here for the shadow map I guess
which is fine so this is interesting
because it's kind of like
it's also got that approach you know
where where like this is kind of a pod
data struct right this is the actual
like specification for that texture so
what kind of texture would you like to
create by the way what do you guys think
of Peter's uh color Style
a little bit different than mine I'm
trying to get ripped from jet brains ah
disgusting didn't tweet the things I
didn't like
because like most of it yeah pretty much
so you can see that like this basically
just tells you how to create that
particular object right it's just the
specification for it we can set it up we
can share it it's very easy to copy it
as well like if you want like a spec
that does like 90 of the stuff similar
to another spec then you can just go
ahead and obviously copy it just like a
normal object copy right
um but then this is the line of code
that creates the texture and you can see
it just takes in the spec which tells it
what kind of texture it is so it's a one
by one rgba texture and then we take in
the actual texture data that it will
automatically kind of upload to the GPU
and then internally obviously that will
create like a Vulcan texture and it's
ready to go and it's stored inside this
object so what I like about that is that
it's incredibly simple like from an API
point of view you know as a human kind
of reading this code you can immediately
just be like what's going on here oh
well I'm creating a one by one rgba
texture with this data and it's ready to
use like I don't think this could be
more simple Ellie's not without
sacrificing like the flexibility of
what's possible with this actual API
yeah by the way guys I'm trying to lean
back so that we're both in Focus because
autofocus yeah so don't mind us being
blurry yeah but yeah no like even having
like a specification struck for types
like the application
like it to me it just makes it nicer
because you don't have 20 different
parameters to a Constructor yeah well
that that that's the thing like you know
people don't like
huge functions or huge Constructors with
lots and lots of parameters but then
like you know what happens if what
you're writing is complex yeah you know
that's the thing like I feel like a lot
of programmers who are maybe more like
beginners or inexperienced like you know
they'll always be like they'll look at
code and they'll maybe feel overwhelmed
by it and they'll just be like no this
sucks like I don't understand this or
this is like why are you over
complicating things why are you making
it like this but the thing is there's a
death and over complicating stuff an
over engineering topic that's definitely
a thing like that's a big thing right
but there's a difference between over
complicating something right and just
having a piece of code that actually is
complex because it just does a lot of
stuff yeah like we were talking about
this last night like game engines like
physically do a lot of things yeah
that's why the files are so big that's
why there's so much stuff it's not that
the actual code if you break it down
piece by piece like at least with hazel
like I don't think of course there are
some complicated stuff maybe you know
for someone the shaders and Graphics
passes we might do that might require a
little bit of research to understand but
generally speaking the C plus plus code
I don't think it's that complex yeah
it's just there's physically a lot of it
and I compared it to like you know a
short story versus like an epic right
like an Epic Novel like that obviously
like the two different things like
they're not necessarily going to be
written in like you know one is like I
mean shorter things generally might be
like you know like a children's book is
obviously generally not a thousand pages
long but it's not necessarily like more
difficult to read something that's
longer
because it entirely depends on the
language that is used and the style that
it's written in and so I think with code
as well yeah you can obviously have
something that is uh you know very very
complicated and long or you can have
something that is long but it's written
really cleanly and it's easy to
understand but you know a gay mentioned
just has a lot of things that it
physically has to do and there's no way
around that yeah and like I think that
becomes obvious when you look at some of
his little system is it's just like sure
you know we might have a file that's
5000 lines of code
but when you're actually break it apart
it's not overly complicated it's just
there's a lot of code needed to get the
job done yeah no I definitely say
yeah when it comes to code there's a
huge difference between complex code and
large code okay so the other thing that
uh kind of Peter mentioned a bit earlier
was all this debug code right so again
um just and it's funny how like I feel
like Moses code review could really just
take place in this file because even
though there are other files here
like you know a lot of it seems to be in
Maine yeah um and I mean these files are
huge which a lot of people would look
down on but I don't I think that having
large files is totally okay yeah as long
as it makes sense like meaning that like
you know all of your stuff is kind of
relevant like this is another great
example of why this main function is so
bad there's so many reasons but one of
it is because it's not just doing one
thing it's not just doing like a couple
things it's literally like everything
from you know setting up this game
setting game memory thing which by the
way we probably should take a look at a
little bit later as well just because
this is kind of unique yeah
um game State actually had like an
application oh yeah
but a safe destructive data yeah that's
the thing like it which again it's fine
like it's I like I don't agree with this
I would make it more object-oriented but
it's fine to have it this way if that's
who you are as long as you still make an
application.cpp file that contains those
related Global functions yeah like you
don't want to just put everything here
and I mean the stuff here isn't even in
a function it's in the main function
yeah you know so all of this all of this
is just kind of floating around here but
again like with the main function
specifically it's just because there's
everything from like you know game State
game memory initialization those kind of
systems to like sdl and creating a
window to or initializing opengl to
loading data to you know obviously
running the game Loop all of that stuff
yeah it's like that oriented programming
is perfectly fine and it's you know you
should be using dot oriented programming
at times it's when you have data
oriented programming but there's no
structure to it that it becomes an issue
for me because it's like there's nothing
wrong with you know working in C for an
example just because it doesn't have
classes and Constructors it's still fine
because you can still emulate that and
people haven't doing that for decades
it's just when when when you have like
data oriented programming in terms of
the actual data structures but then
everything else just dumped into random
places that's when it becomes an issue
for me I kind of I'm not sure if this is
data oriented kind of programming like
well at least the way like I mean the
way I Define data or into programming is
it's specifically designed in a way like
where you're you're paying attention
obviously to like the memory layout to
the cache coherency yeah to all of that
stuff right just by what he's done I
mean I'd probably call this more of like
just procedural kind of programming yeah
where it's like you know you just have
your structures which contain data and
then you just have functions which run
stuff on that data there's just
everywhere like in the entire project
really uh it's not just like in the main
function there's other main function is
like half of it yeah
um there's just a lot of these if def
debugs which actually like strip a lot
of the code from release builds and like
obviously you have to strip stuff from
release builds because you you're gonna
have code that you know shouldn't run in
release mode because it's just there for
debuggability which actually let me stop
you right there this is also why I haste
this idea of debug and release because
there has to be like in my mind there
has to be three configurations yeah
there has to be that's why Hazel has
debug release and dist yeah because like
the problem is debug implies no
optimization and like debug to me really
means like break point IDE kind of
debugging yeah you know and for that you
obviously can't really optimize code
can't really inline code at least not as
well you can't go too crazy with the
optimization otherwise you won't retain
that original code structure that lets
you kind of inspect every variable you
know you'll strip stuff out there might
not be used but that you wanted to debug
because you're working on you're in the
middle of working on something you know
yeah like debugging that's what debug is
right but the problem is if you just
want to have debug rendering which like
if we look at this code as well like you
know debug Shader like this stuff is
drawing debug graphics like you
absolutely want that to run not only in
debug because debug first of all might
be too slow yeah like that's another
thing right like because debug has an
optimization
like yeah it's great for breakpoint
debugging but it's not good for
debugging within the tools that you've
built into the application yeah like if
a game engine editor ran in debug mode
it would be very very slow like it could
be like 10 FPS
right and it's unusable so basically you
definitely want to like be able to run
everything and release and still have
all of your debug tools available to you
so that's I think the weirdest thing to
me straight away apart from again these
if devs that just kind of make
everything dirty but like it's just the
fact that like you know you're stripping
the set of release builds yeah like this
stuff is really useful yeah it's kind of
like um I I looked at that code I did
Card review of a project where they did
um I think it was like a ray Tracer and
then they had debug single threaded and
released multi-threaded yeah and it's
like that's two different code like
that's entitled two different like that
shouldn't be you know if you want to
have multi-threaded or single threaded
and you you absolutely want that to be
compile time make a separate macro or
like a separate kind of Define that's
like multi-threaded or not so that you
can then be like okay I want single
threaded debug mode or multi-threaded
debug mode because you might want to be
debugging your multi-threading code yeah
you know like it's weird when people
kind of tie stuff you know to debug even
though I guess in a way that makes sense
I mean it is possible though like we
didn't really look at this though it's
possible that we're just wrong about
this like I mean this this might not be
the debug configuration
like this is defined anywhere might be
in the old script
um that's just yeah so it's defined the
debug is on
and this is why this is a debug build
yeah they don't have a release built so
so interestingly they don't seem to have
in the build script there doesn't seem
to be a release build they're just like
I'm just looking at debug build finish
debug build unsuccessful like
everything's a debug build yeah so
there's no concept of release
configuration at all I don't know it's
weird it's like it's so annoying to then
go through and be like let me add
another one of these for release like
just use use either visual studio with
Visual Studio project files and a
solution and everything or use like
pre-make or even like cmake would be
better than this to be completely honest
and that's saying a lot honestly
probably even using make on a Windows
but bit better than the Mac which you
know that requires a whole rabbit hole
that requires reading like a thousand
page book probably probably but yeah
wait you know some of that stuff that's
been put into like these if deaths
should not be uh probably done outside
of a very explicit debug mode some of it
should be done in debug and release but
not a distribution yeah and some of you
probably shouldn't even exist I guess my
main point here would be that you want
to run your your code you want to build
your code with optimization on fast mode
on
but retaining your debug tools yeah
right that needs to be a configuration
because that is the most like how I mean
how often do I run Hazel and debug yeah
like very very rarely only if I'm really
having to step through and debug stuff
yeah usually for higher level stuff it's
always running release mode and I just
use the tools that I've built into Hazel
yeah you know but then this distribution
is for like I'm shipping my game so yeah
absolutely strip all the debug code yeah
like I spent quite a bit of time
debugging Hazel in proper debug mode
um like physics and C sharp scripting
and all of that requires me to very uh
like step through each line just and
have all of the info that I can get from
it and it like that's painful and you
know I can't imagine doing that in a
even more complex engine a lot of uh
projects and I think it's a default in
cmake they'd call it Rel with debug yeah
where you have some optimizations on and
you have some symbols on but not all of
them and then there might be some other
options like debug renderer so you can
actually visualize the data itself yeah
the only like in again Hazel like
debugging release the only real
difference is that like it is the
optimization really it's just
optimization but then release will add
stuff like inlining and like actual just
code optimization on and you know faster
floating Point Precision that kind of
stuff but like dist is the only config
that actually strips debugs yes you know
like debug symbols are very present in
release still because that's still an
internal build as far as we're concerned
dist is the only build that gets
distributed and so of course we want to
strip all like the function names and
all the symbols yeah you know from that
like the debug information but I guess
my point of view is that if it's not if
it's still internal then like why remove
stuff that helps debugging like internal
should mean safe meaning that I'm not
part of about being hacked from within
my own company hopefully so like it's
fine that we you know retain all that
stuff obviously yeah because like here
we have I'm not sure what screen space
vertex does but it like presumably uh
there's some like physics Collision
debug rendering going on
um and having that in release mode is
incredibly useful especially considering
like physics on its own can be quite
heavy and you you really want to be able
to debug the information accurately and
you can't do that if each physics tick
takes you know 25 milliseconds so these
kinds of things probably should have
just been a runtime Boolean that you can
toggle on and off the other big thing
about debug card as well like the whole
if def debug you know because that comes
up a lot like if we just go through this
file
and I was like
seven or eight times so the thing is
like obviously that's polluting the code
but also when you're reading stuff like
this you know it's it's really quite
annoying to stumble upon stuff that's
purely for debug and then obviously you
have to scroll past that and kind of
keep going yeah right like you I feel
like because debug code like this is
clearly supposed to be it's kind of
circumstantial like it's only on in
certain configurations like to me it's
kind of like an optional module like you
know you can compile this with extra
debugging stuff kind of present yeah and
so since it's an optional module it
should be it should act like one it
should be separated out into like a
separate file ideally that is just like
okay this is like I don't know what this
is like some kind of debug Graphics
stuff so make a file called debug
Graphics you have your debug Graphics
header you have your CPP file you can
conditionally include that file for
compilation only if you want debugging
kind of enabled and so what what you're
kind of doing there is you're separating
it from the mainline code and you're
making it non-intrusive anymore so that
it doesn't kind of inject itself into
there and it would only be kind of used
if it's actually kind of present and I
think a really good kind of comparison
to what we have in Hazel is
um we have you know the scene rantra and
then we have something called the scene
renderer panel and the scene renderer
panel has an online GUI render function
that is only present in hazelnut which
is our editor and you can see that like
there's a lot of iron gooist there's a
lot of UI stuff here so what this does
is it just gives you an entire panel
inside the game engine editor that you
can use to like control the graphic
settings you know access kind of you
know Graphics debugging tools and stuff
like that that are relevant to the scene
renderer which is what we use to render
scenes in Hazel and you can see that
like again it is a completely separate
file and we can just be like you know
what this file not compiled for
distribution but in the past it used to
be inside the scene renderer file and
that was annoying because this is a huge
file but that was annoying because
obviously if it's inside this file then
we'd either have to like put use macros
or kind of if devs to strip that out and
it kind of makes this file even longer
and not so much relevant because you
know the scene renderer like it's
supposed to render scenes the ideal
thing for that would be you know it
contains only the code necessary to
render a scene and then extra stuff that
is only relevant to the game engine's
editor can either be only in the kind of
editor module so we can only have that
in hazelnut for example or if we still
want it present for like debug or
release builds in the game Run time it
could also still be in the common Hazel
Library but the point is that it's not
kind of a requirement of the scene
renderer class to necessarily include
debug stuff like you're kind of drawing
that out and you're making about an
optional extra Edition that is not
intrusive at all to this kind of primary
code third base and to me that's also a
really important thing that you could do
here like you know you could kind of
bring that out into a debug renderer
that is only present in whatever
configuration you want and then set up
your build system to just not compile
those CPP files in certain configs um
and that would just be a lot I think a
lot cleaner yeah I think another example
of that would be in physics there is
yeah it's fair Collision check I believe
it was we have this if that debug which
first of all has a runtime check as well
which you know is fine but it seems to
submit actual geometry information for
rendering the debug information for like
this Collision check
which I I can see why they would might
put it here initially while they're
writing the function so they can test
everything
but for actual like you know in a proper
project I would probably have put this
as a thing in the debug render and it
would have some sort of internal State
as to whether or not it should render
the debug information for the physics
and I think we have that in uh in Hazel
as well although that might be in scene
render
um
not actually I think this is one of the
things in Hazel that I don't quite like
yeah so in Hazel it's actually in the
scene which probably should be in the
scene renderer but it's still it it's
not part of the actual Collision check
yeah so in my opinion it shouldn't
necessarily be right here it's weird as
well because like sorry one thing I
noticed is the debug memory is not part
of this and I feel like the reason why
it's not part of this is because see
it's a required parameter yeah for this
function right so sphere Collision check
absolutely has to take in debug memory
which may or may not be used I guess
based on if this
this macros on like if this Define is on
yeah so that's a really good example of
why this stuff needs to be separated
like you should just have your sphere
Collision check which does just the
actual Collision check that it's
supposed to do just the math really for
that and then an entirely separate
function in the debugger Android that
could be used to visualize that and like
again there's no reason why if like if
this stuff is actually doing like well I
mean what does this need it needs
position and velocity and stuff and
maybe this stuff like it's positioned in
velocity are just kind of passed in
anyway so they're not like calculated
using this but even if they were
dependent on this code you can just
either copy and paste this code or
separate this part up into a different
function whatever you want but the point
is there's nothing wrong with
potentially even duplicating this code
just for the debug rendering if it means
that debug rendering is completely
separate from the mainline kind of
implementation because again I guess my
point is it should be kind of like water
and oil right you have your water and
then the oil sits on top and it's
completely separate it's completely
clean when it starts being mixed
together are and you just have debug
stuff and debug rendering intertwined
with your real code like that just kind
of creates a huge mess unless you're
maybe temporarily doing it while you're
writing this function itself yeah doing
it temporarily while you're writing it
uh can be really useful
but once you're done with the function
and you know that it's well you know it
works for now like you should move this
out to a place where it doesn't
interfere with the purpose of this
particular function which is to check
for a collision its purpose isn't to do
rendering this shouldn't in my opinion
should be aware of rendering at all it
should just be practically pure math
yeah all right last thing we kind of
wanted to touch on is at the very
beginning of this main function we have
this concept of game memory and we call
game memory dot allocate right so what
this seems to be is a struct of memory
blocks and like you know here you're
using a function so it's clearly not
like strictly I guess C style where it's
like all of the structs that you ever
use in all the classes structs you ever
use are just pure D types like they're
not but anyway
um this has a bunch of memory locks and
memory blocks are up here they seem to
just be a pointer to block a memory
which you can potentially request and
then the allocate function will just do
a bunch of math to calculate the total
allocation size in bytes for all of
these different Engine Systems and then
you'll allocate that basically into a
single block of memory and then kind of
just segregate the blocks so that you
have a pointer to each category you know
within that one big memory allocation
which is a very interesting concept like
I usually would be on board with
something like this because it does
result in just faster a faster program
because if you pre-allocate everything
first of all you have a nice big block
of memory second of all it's all
contiguous yeah you know all the
allocations are kind of free within that
right because all you're doing is just
moving pointers you're not actually
doing any memory allocation and again
it's all kind of close together
physically it's like you've almost
allocated a custom stack yeah point
exactly yeah
um and so it's good but what I don't
like about it
is how difficult it makes your life you
know when you're using this system
because first of all again you need to
make sure that you have all of these
defined set up right like I I'm gonna
have you know how many is this even
there's 10 million one million 10
million I think right by the way in C
plus plus you can do stuff you can do
you can do this yeah um which is super
useful so yeah you know you have to be
like oh yeah 10 million votes which
first of all could potentially be a huge
waste of memory yeah right because you
don't know how much you need but also if
you do happen to exceed that it'll crash
which is you know an issue we currently
have with Hazel's food your Android
because I did the same thing so I'm
guilty of doing stuff like this as well
and it sucks like I've been through this
I don't like it so this is kind of like
at that awkward
stage you know in life where you're like
let's just say halfway between child and
adult and you don't know what you're
doing and because this is halfway
between just using a C plus plus as
memory allocation tools which are great
like in in terms of ease of use I want
memory let me just run new and that's it
I'll get my memory done sorted is it the
most efficient run time no but it's
definitely the easiest if you're the
programmer right and the other side of
the spectrum is like an actual like
potential Arena allocator or whatever
per system or whatever which would speed
up the program potentially significantly
right and just be like a more efficient
way to handle like the memory needs that
your engine or application might have
but this is in that in that awkward
stage in between where like it's not
easy it's not resizable it's not
adjustable at all you have to decide up
front at compile time exactly how much
memory you want to allocate which might
be true it's not going to be the perfect
amount right it's going to be either too
much or 2 too little too little means it
crash too much means waste right and
also using this stuff was the biggest
issue for me like you know check this
out oh I want to store the player
transform let me just call
memory.transforms.request from block one
like what like you know what I mean as
opposed to what like what is player
transform it's an auto oh that's a
memory request and then you have to be
like player transform dot memory
position right like so transforms is a
memory block of transform which contains
these things right so what like the
alternative will kind of be like
you know
where's Sonic are this yeah so okay
so Ctrl shift oh just uh shift and there
okay and then you just you know you just
do transform dot position equals I guess
my point is that like you know if you've
gone from this
to this
you know which in my mind is like
like that's crazy yeah you know you've
made life so much harder for yourself
like and again like yes it might be
faster on the on the CPU side of things
which is great I'm all for that but uh
what I'm saying is that your goal should
be I want it to be like this now you're
not gonna be able to get it perfectly
like this and this is on the stack as
well but there's no reason why you can't
make it not this specific yeah right
like you need to find a better way to
make this API so kind of retain the
usability and how intuitive it is right
to kind of be as closely as possible to
I guess like either the bass C plus plus
or just like a good API right so your
goal is kind of to make this transition
from let's just say worse performance I
mean this is on the stacks this is
actually ideal but let's just say this
was on the Heap right from kind of worst
performance to better performance but
you're trying to make that transition as
frictionless as possible that's the key
word frictionless you want it to be
smooth yeah with something like the
memory allocation
um strategy Harry I mean first of all
they did live a common saying they they
know it's not good and that is
problematic for all the reasons listed
previously but this is a job interview
yeah as I'm concerned exactly it's just
too verbose first of all
to actually like use the API it's you
don't want to have to go through all
these hoops just to get a new transfer
what I would preferably want is to be
able to do just a stack allocated
transform you know set all my data on
all of that uh possibly store that in
some kind of component or on an entity
and then what you could do is you could
have a essentially a pre-allocated
buffer in say your rendering system
because your renderer needs to know the
transforms and I should go when you
submit matches and entities for
rendering you just put all of the
transforms into that buffer starting in
zero
and once you've done that you know you
can go ahead and render everything at
the correct positions and all that and
yes that does result in a copy operation
but you know so does this
these are all copy assignments but yeah
like the way I probably would have done
this particular like allocation strategy
might have been through some something
like a um a lazy allocator that just
grows as needed preferably not
uh land nearly by just incrementing by
one instead it might do what standard
Vector does which is uh I believe Grows
by 50 percent
um
because that way 50 I think in mscc and
times everywhere else yeah and like that
way you you still get that resizability
but you won't grow so much that you end
up using a lot of unnecessary memory or
at least it will take you quite a long
time to get to that point but this this
doesn't grow at all does it no no this
thing's just from a fixed thing but you
can you can't just see the amount of
items and obviously the amount of
transforms that there are here have been
reserved to be Max transforms which is a
thousand yeah and then I guess all
you're saying here is that I'd like one
please yeah and you get I guess
basically a pointer a rapid pointer into
that one transform which you can then
use yeah another problem I just realized
that this is there's nothing preventing
you from writing outside of this
it's like sure I'm requesting one but I
could easily just end up you know
hiding yeah way outside yeah because if
you change the one to a two then
suddenly you can you know I mean because
obviously you could just another way to
write this would be right so that was
that's identical to what he had before
but obviously you only have one and if
you suddenly change it to two then
obviously array index one is now valid
as well yeah and so I guess I mean yeah
but I think the way it actually like
does it is
like if you take a look in here
it just sets it to uh item index into
block which means that like if I just
say here I request
three
the thing is the pointer is obviously is
pointing to contiguous memory yeah so
what's to stop me from you know this
could be done accidentally if you're
doing it in a loop like I could still
end up riding into index 10. yeah and
like this is valid yeah in terms of the
compiler no but it'll also be valid in
run time until you end up overriding
that because the allocator thing starts
a free block of memory is there any kind
of freeing uh I don't see anything yeah
this so this is just a you can't reuse
memory here either yeah so that's
obviously not good nothing you do can be
transient everything is permanent yeah
and also I was I was just I was just
thinking about this while you were
talking is that like obviously like you
know you're riding into player transform
this is what you're dealing with so
you're not dealing with transforms yeah
you're dealing with memory requests of
transforms which means that when you
actually want to use it for something
such as like hey here's the player
entity player entity just has an index
and that index is the index of like the
memory request yeah and then you create
like a render entity from that and then
I guess that transform index like it's
just I feel like it's it's adding an
extra level of interaction and
complexity to everywhere because you
can't just pass objects or whatever
around you end up passing
some kind of memory request indices
which yeah so I'm not a big fan of that
either especially because it doesn't
like this literally adds nothing these
systems are fine I feel as long as they
are abstracted away yeah because that
really should be the goal when they're
at the foreground then they make
everything a lot harder yeah and like
that kind of goes back to like what I
was saying with um
renderer having like a transform buffer
that's first of all contained inside the
renderer itself so you don't have to
interact with that directly as the user
and so what you just end up doing is
saying Hey I want to submit transform to
the renderer and this is the Transformer
I want to submit and if you if you
really don't want to do a copy here you
know pause it by reference you should
probably pass it by reference because
it's a transform it's not small and then
that could be stored internally in a
buffer in the renderer which can then be
used to draw entities at that transform
um yeah so I don't know there's lots of
other stuff we could talk about uh but I
think that I'm probably going to end it
here hopefully those three points are
kind of helpful I guess we decided to
kind of pick a few
points and expand on them rather than
actually go through every line of code
just because that's a little bit
unmanageable but thank you guys for
watching hope you enjoyed the video and
if you did don't forget to hit the like
button if you want me to review your
code then send it into channelreview
gmail.com there'll be some instructions
in description below and finally
brilliant.org slash the channel check it
out I'll see you guys next time goodbye